pour raymond guy la migration des
données de statistique canada vers des
nuages informatiques pose un risque
considérable on sait était toujours de
la possibilité de se faire arnaquer
l'ontarien qui s'y connaît en la matière
est en lui-même victime du vol de
données chez desjardins et life l'add on
sait pas où ça va de ces données là on
est donc on fait confiance à une sottise
canada mais aussi parce qu'est ce qu'ils
font donc on sait pas qui en a donné
dans des documents internes l' agence
fédérale soulève des préoccupations
quant à l'accès et l'utilisation
possible des données canadiennes tant
d'autres pays comme les etats-unis ce
qui préoccupe des experts en cyber
sécurité
le groupe f aux nuages x évidemment
c'est que les données ne sont plus
contrôlés par la personne qui les genres
n'est évidemment on va aller faire
affaire avec des entreprises comme
amazon microsoft gougaud thaçi canada se
veut rassurante pour traiter les
informations les plus sensibles
l'agent ce qu'ont toujours utilisé des
centres de données sécurisées plutôt que
le nuage
les craintes au réal mais nous allons
prendre les mesures nécessaires avant de
avant de migrer les données
le statisticien en chef envisage un
transfert des données par étapes en
stockant d'abord des informations non
sensibles et non classifiés dans le
nuage
les données dites protégées le migreront
selon lui que lorsque les systèmes
d'info nuagiques seront jugés sur au spo
l'outil le problème c'est qu'ils manient
l'outil cet expert remet en question la
capacité de statistique canada de
protéger ses informations et les plus
grands cerveaux on se bat sécurité sont
pour certains milieux publics soient
plus dans le privé donc déjà qu'une
pénurie de personnel dans ce milieu
laulan le statisticien en chef espère
pouvoir achever ce virage numérique
c'est tout va bon train
d'ici les deux ou trois prochaines
années il suffirait de montigny radio
canada toronto